vestido de blanco es empujado por
decenas de paramilitares antidisturbios
y escoltado hacia un coche blindado el
ex Primer Ministro pakistaní fue
detenido a su llegada al tribunal
superior de islamabad un arrestó que su
equipo jurídico calificó de secuestro
hoy cuando fue a hacerse la prueba
biométrica le detuvieron en las
dependencias del tribunal le golpearon
en la cabeza con un palo y le rociaron
algo que le dejó casi inconsciente
después le metieron en el vehículo
al tribunal para enfrentar tan solo una
de las decenas de causas por corrupción
que tiene pendientes desde que fue
destituido el año pasado tras una moción
de censura en la asamblea nacional pero
la antigua estrella de Cricket sigue
siendo muy popular y cuando el pti el
movimiento pakistaní por la justicia
llamó a sus miembros a paralizar el país
la atención se disparó en las calles de
las principales ciudades
lo que han hecho no es gamberrismo no es
terrorismo una persona había ido a
comparecer ante el tribunal ahora dónde
está el tribunal supremo Dónde está el
Tribunal Superior Dónde están los jueces
la crisis lleva meses gestándose ya que
ibrankana desafiado abiertamente al
ejército pakistaní al actual gobierno y
acusado a la agencia de espionaje del
país de estar detrás de un complot
fallido por asesinarle al pasado
noviembre el ex dirigente quiere volver
al poder y pide elecciones anticipadas
antes de octubre
[Aplausos]